[Music]
on this sunday night the countdown is on
for women in the united states as demand
increases at abortion clinics before
bans begin am i going to be prosecuted
though abortion is legal here the
barriers experts say could get worse
despite the fact we're supposed to have
a health care system that is equal and
equitable for all it's not and what's
coming next from the conservative
supreme court attacks intensify in
ukraine what russia claims while hitting
civilian targets a highly respected
conservative voice speaks out against
her own i'm very worried for our party
our exclusive interview with retired
conservative senate leader marjorie
lebritton as the leadership race gears
up canada day skiing
the hill where it's cold enough to open
up runs this long weekend
global national with bara nasser
good evening thank you for joining us we
are now in the final days of abortion
being legal in some u.s states clinics
are seeing a rush of patients patients
who had autonomy over their body and
reproductive rights under law just days
ago
that comes as calls grow louder and
stronger for joe biden to take action
and protect abortion rights nationwide
while rallies continue across the
country today to protest friday's
monumental strike down of roe v wade
many are calling on the u.s president to
use federal land as a safe haven in
states with a ban or to severely
restrict the practice altogether
tennessee is one place that has one of
the most restrictive bans and it's
expected to come into effect in the
coming days and that's where we find our
own jackson prosco tonight and jackson
there fear over abortion access is
quickly turning into reality
that's right farah they know the ban is
coming the question for women and health
care providers is what does life look
like once that ban is in effect there
are a lot of troubling questions and a
lot of very real concerns
one of the most famous destinations in
the u.s may soon be defined by what it
refuses to allow as tennessee enacts a
deeply restrictive abortion ban one with
no exceptions for rape or incest that's
heartbreaking for me and it's going to
be really hard for me to tell that news
to my patients when they ask me where
can i go to get an abortion dr katrina
green is an emergency physician in
nashville
once the state's trigger ban comes into
effect in july she will not only have to
worry about her patients she must also
worry about herself am i going over the
law am i
going to be prosecuted soon doctors will
only be able to perform an abortion if
the life of the mother is deemed at risk
a term poorly defined women are going to
die as a result of this there will be
doctors who hesitate to act because
they're worried about breaking the law
and going to jail and women will suffer
and they will die the uncertainty
extends to the local planned parenthood
clinic where staff will continue
providing abortions until they no longer
can
after that their only option will be to
help women leave the state we are going
to do everything we can to make sure
that finances and logistics does not
stand in the way of any person getting
the abortion care they need and we are
also going to continue to fight like
hell to get this right back in tennessee
the odds of that seem slim tennessee has
already criminalized providing
abortion-inducing drugs by mail
violators face up to 20 years in prison
the hopelessness felt by many was heard
during sunday mass at saint anne's
episcopal church
a lot of people sure aren't feeling very
free
free
to make choices about our bodies free to
live as the people we're called to be
this is kind of just the beginning in
this deeply conservative state reverend
kira austin young preaches that faith
and choice can co-exist really tries to
balance what we believe as christians
that life is holy and beautiful and
deserves to be nurtured
with the knowledge that life doesn't
always work out the way we think it
might or should but it's now too late to
change the course of reproductive
freedom in tennessee with just weeks
left until the unprecedented rollback of
women's rights
and polls show that the state's
restrictive abortion ban is vastly out
of touch with what the majority of
people in this state actually want in a
survey from just last month 80 percent
of people in this state said there
should be some legal access to abortion
in at least some instances and that's up
from 40 percent less than a decade ago
it shows you how fast the public tide of
opinion has swung in favor of some
abortion access farah
jackson proskow in nashville thank you
jack said in its strike down of roe v
wade at least one conservative supreme
court justice signaled that more rights
could be on the line increasing worries
among millions of americans about what's
to come jennifer johnson has more on the
fight to ensure the controversial
decision isn't the beginning of other
historic human rights rulings being
reconsidered by the conservative court
i'm scared as a woman as protests
continue outside the u.s supreme court
there are concerns the conservative
majority will now hear challenges to
other court cases including those
protecting the right to contraceptives
and same-sex marriages next they're
going to come for birth control and
they're just going to keep going for
everyone's rights our community is
scared in the opinion striking down roe
v wade justice clarence thomas said the
court's rulings of both contraceptives
and same-sex marriage should be
re-examined two other conservative
justices disagreed there was no one that
joined in that opinion so
this is not about contraceptions this is
not about same-sex marriage governor
hutchinson says contraceptives will
still be sold in arkansas but already
abortions are illegal there many legal
experts are concerned though about the
court overturning the ruling that
legalized same-sex marriage we now know
that a majority of the supreme court
wouldn't have recognized them in the
first place as to whether they would now
reject them the key point is that
they've only been around recognized by
the supreme court for 5 10 15 years a
few members of congress want to impeach
the justices who they say misled
lawmakers on their abortion views but
that has no chance of passing in the
divided senate others are investigating
what can be done on a federal level to
protect a woman's right to abortion
women are not second-class citizens
and the government is not the one that
will decide about the continuation of a
pregnancy as 26 states move ahead with
plans to make abortions illegal or
severely restrict them dozens of large
corporations are publicly pledging to
cover employee travel expenses for those
who have to go to other states to get
the procedure
the washington d.c area homes of several
of the conservative supreme court
justices remain heavily guarded with
protesters outside a new poll shows 67
percent of american women disapprove of
the court's ruling the rest of the world
is laughing at us and standing
up you know with their mouths open how
can america do this the next test for
the country's political future will come
in the november elections as some
americans see their rights being taken
away while others celebrate a battle
they've been waging since the woman
known as jane rowe won her case nearly
50 years ago
jennifer johnson global news washington
as rallies continued across the united
states several canadian cities held
their own events in support of abortion
rights this weekend and while abortion
is legal in canada advocates say that
abortion access is still a big problem
in many parts of this country as heather
urux west explains they fear those
barriers could soon get
worse maggie butler was on vacation in
montreal when her right to health care
significantly changed in my home state
of wisconsin abortion is now illegal as
of friday and i'm considering moving to
either a different state maybe to canada
who knows that a right to a safe
abortion held by women in the u.s for
decades could be suddenly taken away
inspired rallies in several canadian
cities over the weekend
in montreal halifax and toronto what the
right must understand in canada is that
we will not stand for this here we will
defend a woman's right to choose we will
defend people's rights to love who they
choose we will defend people to choose
their gender identity abortions remain
legally available in this country and
funded by canada's health care system
but accessing the service can be
difficult for those living in isolated
or rural communities despite the fact
we're supposed to have
you know a
health care system that is equal and
equitable for all it's not the only
abortion clinics in alberta for example
are located in the province's two major
cities if you're trying to navigate
taking a bus down to edmonton or calgary
you know greyhound services don't even
exist anymore so if you're a low income
if you have a huge family already if
you're working two to three jobs just to
pay your paycheck
you don't have that ability to travel
somewhere for two to three days i need
you to talk about abortion it's why
advocates say this moment in time needs
to serve as a wake-up call to anyone
concerned about reproductive rights even
though it's happening
south of the border
you know those things
have a way to creep up
on us
and why protesters gathered on the
streets of many canadian cities this
weekend say they won't back down heather
urex west global news calgary
to the war in ukraine now russian forces
have launched more waves of missile
attacks that have killed and injured
innocent civilians these include a new
round of bombardments on keefe which
comes just days after the european union
agreed to formally accept ukraine's
candidacy into the eu
sean o'shea is in ukraine and has more
on the deadly day in its
capital this happened at a car wash
russian rockets hit a structure that
included a repair facility three people
were killed four others were treated in
hospital
here in eastern ukraine there's been a
definite uptick in the number of missile
and rocket attacks over the last few
days and in keeve this morning the
capital was targeted for the first time
since early june
it's now a daily experience somewhere in
ukraine as civilians remain in the
russian firing line
there were at least four large
explosions in the center of the city
in this apartment building rescuers
worked to save a seven-year-old girl she
was sleeping peacefully until a cruise
missile hit her home said the country's
foreign minister it's the second time
this apartment has been attacked
rescuers were busy saving residents at
another building
and at a different location someone
stuck under broken concrete screamed for
help the city's mayor was at the scene
we know the couple of people
inside
at yet another location in kiev a large
blast left a crater in a kindergarten
playground all as russia continues to
deny it's targeting civilians
claiming its army is hitting three
ukrainian military training locations on
sunday
this just days after ukrainian forces
retreated from several done-esque the
eastern city once home to 100 000 people
is now entirely under russian control
thank you to the soldiers who evacuated
us from there says this woman named
elena she and others are now out and on
their way to a safer place russia
celebrates his biggest victory in this
war since the capture of mario paul last
month sean o'shea global news kharkiv
ukraine
two canadian naval ships are deploying
for the first time to the baltic sea and
the north atlantic to help counter
russia's aggression the crews of hmcs
kingston and hmcs summerside bid
farewell to loved ones departing halifax
today to take part in operation
reassurance the nato mission led by
canada's military in europe the pair of
ships will help with demining operations
on their four-month deployment
in south africa police are investigating
the mysterious deaths of at least 22
young people some children found inside
a popular nightclub
forensic teams are scouring the club in
the coastal town of east london looking
for any signs of what may have caused
the tragedy the victims are mostly in
their late teens early twenties but
police say some of them are as young as
13 years old autopsies will be done to
determine the cause of death but police
have ruled out a stampede
coming up unity for ukraine tops the
agenda at the g7 but what critics say
should be just as urgent
plus forget the cabin cottage and
campfire where you can hit the slopes
for canada day weekend
prime minister justin trudeau is in
southern germany for his latest summit
with g7 and european leaders and with
russia's war on ukraine still raging the
conflict remained a top priority for day
one of the three-day summit our chief
political correspondent david aiken is
traveling with the pm and has more on
how the leaders are determined to show
unity against russian aggression
[Music]
prime minister justin trudeau touched
down in munich on a sunny sunday morning
was greeted by a traditional bavarian
hunting party and ban
then took off in a helicopter for a
castle in elmau in the bavarian alps a
summit with g7 and other world leaders
where the dominant topic of discussion
will be russia's invasion of ukraine and
all the global turmoil that has caused
lots of hard work to do on climate
change on ukraine
and on and on growing the economy and
helping our citizens
the key objective for trudeau and all
leaders here maintaining the unity and
resolve of the g7 in support of ukraine
we have to stay together
because putin has been counting on from
the beginning
and somehow nato would
and the g7 would
splinter
but we haven't and we're not going to
good messages that we all made to stay
united
but protesters insist climate change
must also be at the top of the g7 agenda
and leaders here will indeed spend time
talking about that tackling climate
change is both a challenge and a massive
opportunity
on climate the eu is the leader and we
are fully committed to the paris
agreement still with those fresh rocket
attacks on keeves sunday ukraine remains
the most urgent topic on the table here
right now and on monday the ukrainian
president himself will join in vladimir
zelinski will dial in by video
conference to talk to justin trudeau and
other g7 leaders about what more the g7
can do to support ukraine in its war
against russia pharah
david aiken in germany thank you david
ahead a retired conservative senator
speaks out critical of her own party in
this global news exclusive the one event
that really changed things for her
you're watching global national
a high-profile veteran of the
conservative party is speaking out over
its future in an exclusive interview on
the west block former conservative
senate leader marjorie lebreton
expressed worries for the party she's
worked with for decades over the
divisive direction it now seems to be
heading as abigail beeman reports
lebreton is pushing back against the
dangerous rhetoric growing popular among
its members including those running for
leadership
i'm very worried for our party marjorie
lebreton retired conservative senate
leader decades of experience with the
party and widely respected in an
exclusive interview on the west block
she says she feels she no longer has a
home in the conservative party i really
fear that the great accommodation that
was reached between stephen harper and
peter mckay
in the in the fall of 2003
is is fracturing beyond repair causing
her the most concern members who embrace
convoy protests
the whole idea of
wrecking a cornerstone of conservatism
in law and order was sort of really
really upsets me and i'm very very
worried last week key organizers were
welcomed by some conservative mps on
parliament hill including leadership
hopeful leslie lewis
there are further rallies planned for
canada day and the summer the main
cornerstones of conservatism is law and
order and law and order is law and order
and illegal blockades are illegal
blockades whether they're at
a border crossing a pipeline a railway a
railway line they're illegal lebreton is
also disappointed in the current
leadership race wanting candidates to
focus more on issues less on personal
attacks it's never great when you have
something like senator lebreton
expressing concerns but at the same time
i'm less worried about permanent
divisions in the party i think whoever
wins the leadership will
try to bring people together to heal
those divisions
lebreton resigned from leadership
candidate pierre paliev's riding board
of directors over his support of the
convoy global news reached out to his
campaign for comment but did not get a
response abigail beeman global news
ottawa
next up the scenes we haven't seen in
two years in canada in-person pride at
one of the biggest parades in the world
[Music]
[Music]
this is the first weekend of summer and
oh it certainly feels like it across
much of british columbia the majority of
the province is under a special weather
statement for heat with temperatures
reaching the low to mid 30's today in
metro vancouver the warmer the normal
weather is expected to stick around
until at least tomorrow
and a very different scene in
neighboring alberta as get this bamps
sunshine village ski resort prepares to
reopen for the canada day long weekend
the resort is reporting 10 centimeters
of fresh snow in the past week adding to
the more than 900 centimeters of snow
the mountain received this season
operators say skiers and snowboarders
will be welcomed back on tuesday with
the hopes of staying open until at least
july 3rd
now there are countless reasons to
celebrate
lgbtq2s plus communities this pride
month of course but it wouldn't be
complete without going to the pride
parade well toronto hit quite a
milestone with its own celebration not
only is it now 50 years since the first
pride parade in toronto this was the
first in-person one since 2019. megan
king has more on the festivities
beads were flying and people were
dancing along the downtown parade route
on sunday as toronto celebrated its 41st
pride parade i'm really excited about
this because we deserve
pride is celebration pride is
passion is everything it's just a fun
event i like coming every year it makes
me feel better and happy and for mothers
such as emily maderick pride events she
says provide a safe space for her
children my children
identify as girl and non-binary so it's
really important for them to get out and
see this representation and just
experience all the love and the
happiness plus we're very into rainbows
this is very important
very important and hopefully we'll send
the message to families to you know
embrace your own
the toronto parade now back after a
two-year pandemic hiatus brought crowds
from across the province and beyond it's
rather amazing because most of us are
from a very small town that's not
mostly
rude people
and
it's just so great to see all the like
pride and rainbows and i'm loving it
love i have a lot of students who um
they struggle with sexuality and just
coming out and it's good to be outside
embrace this and oh my gosh allyship
happy pride
with over 200 contingents and over 200
000 participants even these all the way
from montreal everyone's out here
celebrating pride and love megan king
global news toronto
celebrating pride and love that's what
it's all about happy pride to those of
you who are celebrating it this weekend
and that's global national for this
sunday night i'm farrah nasser and on
behalf of our crew i want to thank you
so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your canada is
a hungry squirrel enjoying a strawberry
in burnaby british columbia we love
seeing your canada keep emailing us
those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com donna we'll be back
with you tomorrow until next time take
care of yourselves and each other good
night
[Music]